I wanted to make this video for years
like literally years maybe even before I
started this channel oh well that was a
long time ago I'd hate to be that oh
shut up stupid young person go back to
shouting at people's shoes and eating
too tight pods
I don't know what kids like I didn't
want this to be a which one do you think
is the most epic Kuras dude sort of
video no instead I wanted to break down
these characters using psychology and
philosophy to help us decide which one
we are more like and I'm not talking
about physically looking like them
though if you did I mean like my dams I
mean if you want to but I digress this
episode is sponsored by better help calm
and we're asking you that acceptably
tough question would you rather be a
Goku or Vegeta okay I can hear you
already all of you crying out there
saying Goku is the obvious answer why
would I want to be Vegeta he's miserable
I like carrots more okay I hear you am i
aggressively trepidatious gaggle of
subscribers but I happen to have a
retort you see in an interview released
in November of 1996 series creator and
currency champion from photographers
Akira Toriyama had this to say son Goku
from Dragon Ball doesn't fight for the
sake of others but because he wants to
fight against wrong guys
so once Dragon Ball got animated at any
rate I've always been dissatisfied with
the righteous hero type portrayal they
gave him I guess I couldn't quite get
them to grasp the elements of poison
that slip in an out of sight among the
shadows so from that we had confirmation
saying Goku isn't all that he's cracked
up to be
or at least in the wider westernized
releases anyway
and so the question remains if given the
choice would you rather be Goku or
Vegeta maybe Albert Einstein can help us
out he said a large part of her attitude
towards things is conditioned by
opinions and emotions which we
unconsciously absorb as children from
our environment so in other words y-you
experience growing up whether you're
aware of it or not plays a large role in
how you express yourself and your
beliefs later in life and Einsteins
pretty much correct here relatively
speaking from the day that Gina was born
he was told that he's the [ __ ] best
and no matter how hard any other saying
would try he would still be the best by
default so naturally you kind of can't
blame him for thinking he's yeah that
and it's this very same belief that
prevents it from showing any compassion
for his fellow Saiyans casting right
it's a NAPA to the wayside without a
moment's thought because to him
they are inconsequential he's the only
one that can become a Super Saiyan and
therefore he's the only one that matters
alternatively Goku story begins as he
loosely and not so loosely re-enacts the
plot to Superman sent to earth as a baby
by a loving father and mother no no
Dragon Ball boy is ruined Bartok -
points for - anyway Goku ends up
learning from his adopted grandpa Gohan
and his first teacher Master Roshi that
he must train consistently because there
will always be someone stronger he needs
to see the strength and others to meet
his own desires which is to fight strong
guys so during the same time the jito
refuses to revive Raddatz and straight
up murders nappa
Goku places his trust in a longtime
enemy which ended up being a
difference-maker for his firstborn son
gohan now this is where things get good
Goku and Vegeta at this point have two
conflicting ideologies Vegeta believes
that he will always be the best and Goku
believes that he can't ever be the best
I'm gonna say right off the bat Vegeta
he isn't Goku's rival for decades Goku
and Vegeta has been touted as the
greatest rivalry in anime history and
that simply isn't true
or at least I don't think so not because
they aren't interesting characters with
complex motivations but because Goku
does not compete with Vegeta or at least
not in the same way Vegeta does with him
no K let me explain Vegeta competes
against Goku and Goku competes with
himself and I think that's an important
distinction that strikes at the core of
this video which I will definitely
discuss in more detail later on -
confidence is silent insecurities are
loud yep
checks out so Vegeta loses but why is he
angry because he lost right
well no Goku has a case for why he's
better than Vegeta and boy that really
rustles Vegeta's jimmies because now he
has to face the reality that he isn't
predestined for anything and that he
never had the right to talk down to
anyone let alone kill them on top of
that he isn't destined to become the
legendary Super Saiyan and will forever
be Frieza slave okay so not ideal but
Goku doesn't get off scot-free here
either he did give Vegeta a glimpse of
reality sure but he also led a literal
maniac that killed a lot of his friends
and threatened his son's life
hmm go why because he wanted to fight
strong guys now you see that poison I
was talking about earlier that was an
entirely selfish act that given the
information on hand at the time could
have played out in terrible ways for all
those that he cared for
okay so let's hit the fast-forward
button here for a bit
okay too far here yes so we find
ourselves building up to the climax of
the cell saga and it's clear the
motivation of both characters is laid to
bear up to this point Vegeta has had his
worldview social standing and body
pummeled by almost every major player at
this point he's witnessed two Saiyans
reach his lifelong dream before him and
now he's being forced to admit that he's
still not good enough
why because Goku does this I know what
I'm being patronized and I don't care
for the suggestion that you're stronger
than me yeah I wasn't really suggesting
this is sort of glossed over in the
series but if you read between the lines
you see this Vegeta has one goal defeat
and surpass Kakarot Goku also has one
goal to get stronger
both of these seem to be the same on the
surface but there's one key difference
and this this ties in perfectly with why
I was saying earlier Goku and Vegeta are
not rivals
Vegeta's goals are not the same as
Goku's they are not competing together
Goku trains indefinitely because it
gives him life it's his passion he could
become the strongest in the universe and
Goku would still train intensely
thinking there would eventually come
some big threat however if you were to
convince him there wouldn't ever be
anyone stronger than him he'd be misery
in that same way if you told the cheetah
he was the strongest in the universe
that no one could ever hope to best him
couldn't be happier Vegeta has a point
where he will stop wanting to be
stronger Goku doesn't this is the sole
reason why Goku will always be stronger
than Vegeta Vegeta chases Goku Goku
chases himself in fact it was Socrates
that said the secret of happiness you
see is not found in seeking more but in
developing the capacity to enjoy less
in other words because Vegeta is
clinging to the past with everything
he's got torturing his body to triple
Goku's efforts he becomes a man obsessed
until suddenly goodbye
this without question was a selfless act
by Goku not doing this out of
selfishness but to bail his son out of a
hole he had dug himself into now this is
a big moment for Gohan yes and he is the
focus of the scene but it was in that
moment a little piece of Vegeta died as
the weeks and months after the cell saga
passed by he eventually came to the
conclusion that he would never get the
chance to have that final fight with
Goku as easily as that his life lost
meaning he had no reason to exist
anymore
in his mind you know it's it's funny
despite not being raised on earth and
despite not being an Earthling Vegeta is
one of the most human characters not
only in this conversation but within the
entire series and for me at least this
was the moment that I really empathize
most with Vegeta's character because
we've all had those days where dark
clouds hang over our heads and this is
where I think boma became instrumental
in Vegeta's life but before we continue
with Vegeta's downward spiral I'd like
to take a minute to talk about something
serious if you've been watching my
videos for long enough you'll know I've
never really had sponsorships in any of
my videos and trust me people have asked
but I generally don't like putting ads
in my videos our mental health is a
serious issue that generally we try to
avoid discussing at all costs and I
think that's an enormous problem which
is why I am proud to say that this video
is sponsored by better health com better
help is a service which provides fast
affordable counseling whether it be by
email message phone call video chat
whatever your preferences with a
counselor of your choice I can
personally stand by better health
because they've helped me being a
youtuber I find myself struggling to
have time for anything these days and
better helps counselor my voice to me
was able to work around my schedule
perfectly it's not a sign of weakness to
talk to someone about something you're
struggling with it's a sign of strength
so this is for you guys if you feel like
talking to a qualified counselor could
be beneficial to you and if you'd like
to support the channel follow the link
in the description down below and start
counseling today I love you all and wish
you the very best you deserve it all
right so we just saw Goku peace out in
an attempt to bail his son out of a bad
situation with Sal a selfless act no
doubt and Vegeta is spiraling into a
depression which will manifest itself in
hikes no case so let's break down some
of the selfless and selfish things these
characters have done in their lives
let's start with Goku he saves the earth
a bunch of times but if we look at that
Toriyama quote again and really look at
those times he did the vast majority are
because he wanted to win a fight
aka the poison in the shadows his fight
with piccolo doesn't count his fight
with Fujiya doesn't count his fight
against Sal doesn't count so we really
only have one that I can think of on the
opposite side we have Vegeta who up
until the end of the boom saga hadn't
really done anything too selfless apart
from sacrifice himself against Buu which
let's be honest is one of the most
selfless acts in the entire series now
let's look at all the times Goku put the
earth in danger during the original run
insisting he be the one to fight Vegeta
alone insisting to let the obvious
murder and psychotic Vegeta live he
insists on fighting purple Hitler alone
until he can't
he helps purple Hitler live which
results in purple Hitler heading to
earth good through the time traveler
from the future who happens to be a
Super Saiyan fails him out of that one
oh and he lets his eleven-year-old son
fight perfect cell on a hunch and don't
say it wasn't a hunch this is the face
of a man that's thinking atom [ __ ] up
and Vegeta the psychotic madman has
threatened the earth three times yep
saying saga with cell and majin buu so
it turns out coke was a bigger threat to
the earth and that's not even counting
Dragon Ball super oh speaking of which
so unsurprisingly Dragon Ball super
shows a lot of these two characters and
a lot of people think and perhaps
rightly so that Fuji is development at
the end of
z was tarnished and seemingly reversed
for the beginning of super and you're
right I'd like anit to Iron Man 3 and
Captain America Civil War
iron man hangs up the mantle in Iron Man
3 but is right back at it in civil war
and his reasoning few years ago I almost
lost her so I trashed on my seats
we had to mop up Hydra and then Ultron
and then and then and then I have
stopped because the truth is I don't
want to stop
saying something like you're better than
me Kakarot is easier than actually
living it and believing it but I digress
let's get into it
within Dragon Ball super Goku is shown
to be working to support his family on a
number of occasions namely at the
beginning of Dragon Ball super picking
cabbages in the Future Trunks arc and at
the beginning of the tournament of power
arc something we know he isn't
particularly fond of doing so that's
progression
good job Goku in saying that he does put
the entire multiverse into potential
danger so call it even also hold the
phone can I just say what's the deal
with this Goku never having kissed
chichi on the lips thing he didn't even
know what that was apparently which begs
the question how did he even go on how
did he go 10 I feel like there's a
darker plot behind the son family
anyways let's talk some Vegeta Vegeta is
a [ __ ] angel in this series for the
most part but even then he probably
saved lives doing that right there are
two enormous moments for his character
towards the end of this series and I
mean [ __ ] huge
ignoring the my bull machine which is
pretty dope I want to focus on the
tournament of power if I can Vegeta
passes up the opportunity to train with
Goku and Wiese in order to be there for
his daughter's birth it's during this
exchange Goku is confused why he's
dedicated to such an activity seeing as
he wasn't there for Goten and didn't
seem to care about not being there for
that Vegeta faced with this decides to
sacrifice time spent doing Goku training
to do something he sees to be more
valuable at the end of the tournament of
power Vegeta finally after seeing Goku
achieve ultra instinct decides that
chasing that form isn't - the right move
that he should try to get stronger his
own way and as a result of not chasing
Goku in that way he achieves something
unique to himself I can't stress how
enormous a moment that is for Vegeta the
man who tortured himself to insane
levels to compete with Goku has decided
not to follow in his shadow but to blaze
his own Trail
he now derives meaning not from go
alone but from his life and his family
he sees that he has value to people as
he exists right now the most human
character so given what we know about
these characters who do you think you
prefer to be Goku finds joy in one thing
consistently but Vegeta has grown to
find joy in a variety of things that
said he will also experience hardships
far more frequently
unlike Goku so I ask you who would you
prefer to be like or who do you think
you are like I really don't think
there's a wrong answer here I personally
choose Vegeta but I can't deny being a
person with no earthly possessions is
quite an attractive prospect either so
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below I can't wait to read
them and again if you'd like to have
someone to talk to you on a daily basis
and want to support this channel click
the link in the description down below
to get to better help calm i 100% stand
by it see you next time guys thank you
so much for watching